[Music]
tonight from quad bakers and Johan and I
work for me night house
hello everyone I'm a nurse from Bad
Santa turtle games and our game fickman
is out today and it's an
action-adventure game which is also a
musical did you why did you want
yeah the game definitely deals with some
like deeper like emotional things and
it's definitely also a personal thing
like a lot of things that we deal with
are things that we can also kind of
relate to as like the people on the team
not not one specific guy but like we
took in like the personal kind of
influences from everyone and tried to
kind of put that in because the game
deals were like the mind of a person you
know and we this mind is kind of maybe
like a collective mind of the people who
are involved in creating the game so
yeah definitely something that that came
from from us and as personal and we have
presenting our first game Lake rhythm
changed
[Music]
the first thing that I noticed about
your game was how strikingly beautiful
it is which obviously is very important
when you're making a walkthrough
simulator because it's all about the
atmosphere that the player is thrust
into when they're playing the game it
has been kind of related to games like
fire watch and gone home how would you
say that your game stands out in a sense
and I don't really like to call it
walking simulator I like to call it the
very slow or adventure game we have a
lot more possible than what you usually
have in this other game some challenges
two-player a little bit more the store
that we're trying to sell is the mystery
story as well where we have all of these
clues that the players can try to like
fit together for themselves before they
actually reach the end so it's not just
following like the normal visual story
that that usually see in this sort of ok
simulator is more of a like finding a
lot of different clues and like solving
puzzles um and progressing in that way
and we just released the lost bear we
can work on for 6 monsters to DVR
platform aunties
but basically imagine is like a virtual
puppeteer in which she watched the game
play out on a 2d stage but around you is
a world similar to that that you're
playing in that changes it to progress
for it the story follows Warner who is a
little girl she loses a teddy bear and
it's the adventure of gaining their
courage it was save little teddy bear
return to a brother yeah that's a really
good memory baby by the way I've tried
to talk to my friends about this game
and they're like what do you mean it's
Judy platformer babies in VR and I'm
like Evan
Jumanji is like an example of like when
you play the game for that world kind of
but there's no Robin Williams showcasing
silent streets
detective adventure game with augmented
reality creatures the first episode has
been out for three months now in App
Store and Google Play and we're here to
present entertainment of the game with
the Apple a arcade features
[Music]
all point of the ideas very new in the
gaming world I mean I haven't seen as
many people playing around with what you
can do in augmented space as much as
virtual reality for instead so what kind
of inspired you to make an augmented
reality game it was a game for four for
Nokia smartphones don't remember exactly
the name of it release say eight years
ago nine eight ninety years ago my
colleague Alex played up back at the
time and it was a geolocation adventure
game with audio now that inspired the
the detective adventure game with the
bits of material and features and wanted
walking to be a big part of that and
then the actual camera thing came in
later because we realized some existing
with meant reality games we're using
that that's it and the reason why there
is not so many games I guess is
augmented reality obviously limits the
settings and
the themes that can be used in the game
it's quite interesting because a lot of
games when they try and show topics like
these will be very serious and there'll
be a bit more on the darker side but
you've chosen to go very innocent very
kind of playful and uplifting why did
you choose to develop a game like this
yeah like I think that's that's a like
part of who we are also like we like
telling jokes and we like doing all
these things and we like drawing
colorful drawings and all these kind of
things and doing crazy music so it's
kind of natural to kind of go about it
that way but I don't necessarily that's
there's a problem that like people can
be like both fun and serious at the same
time you know and associate games I
think alike I think it's it's it maybe
it's a little easier actions you can't
get these things across when you kind of
choose something a little late harder
yes I found that as well because it's
quite a dark game so it can be quite
difficult to see what's around and then
when you realize oh oh that's the light
right there and then the whole the whole
place gets illuminated and even just the
small things like you had a cluster of
candles and you just do one and it
didn't really make much difference with
the lights where as you were lighting
the more you could see everything around
you then I noticed that there is a
wooden sword which I like a lot oh it's
a sword I feel like a badass now yeah so
I think the atmosphere works very nicely
but one thing that I was wondering on
your website it says that it's a
simulation horror game would you say
that this one or maybe a different
different version or different take on
horror so it was more horror before we
we found it to be difficult to tell
intricate story inside Oregon because
everyone was going around like wait for
things to jump out at them so instead
we've changed out the horror game
mechanics towards more even more like
adventuring puzzle solving just to go
around and find clues but if the plot is
still the same it's still like the same
feeling just really creepy ominous
things going to happen and there is of
course still an antagonist in the game
but we don't have any we don't have any
violence we don't even do or anything
like that but the mystery to play will
unravel is where it's very dark in in
itself as well so it's both if it's both
it's not it's a whole themed adventure
game is a 2d side-scrolling platformer
game what's this
how did this idea arise it's so unique
it's so different what are you thinking
of originally just making a
side-scrolling platformer they both
power is obviously really talented 2d
artists but the thing is played that
already rocket cinematic platformer it's
like limbo and inside or check out Jeff
game so we didn't really want to compete
with that
if we put it into bi creates a unique
experience different to the first-person
shooters or the touchy-feely picking
stuff up VR games we wanted to create a
more chilled relaxed experience that you
could become immersed in that world in
2d platformer I lost bear really allowed
us to do that also because I mean
artists Minds one Czech Republic he's
kind of got that heritage of like
Eastern European puppet shows so they
kind of all led into the concept
do you think that making a game using a
has actually enhanced anything
narratively throughout the gameplay
process so I know that the narrative is
quite a massive pivotal aspect of this
game as it is used in the in the first
episode as it has been out I know I
think oh man the reality was more of a
gimmick but with the Alpha why are kids
so much bigger thing because you can do
the proper investigation so you can set
up a room around you or maybe a a murder
scene industries or a morgue scene and
actually in a walk around the body in
collectives or you know open drawers and
cabinets and look inside and stuff like
that so that's way more meaningful I
would stand for a detective adventure
the music is a massive part of the game
every review that I have seen has talked
about how how unique it is how every
boss has their own their own song but
also throughout the game just hitting
random objects you can kind of add to
the music around which is really great
so why do you think the music was so
pivotal what do you think it brings to
the game well I mean from the beginning
of the game we wanted something I was
kind of a like we wanted this painting
that can explore and and then at one
point it's like we need to add something
more to this so it's like we just
figured it'd be cool to try out like
what about they have to character sing
to each other like I really hate
musicals but it's like it could be
really fun to try to like make one so
it's just like let's try that and we try
that and I like I've always liked it I
didn't music right so I've always
actually one of the guys and try that
Michael they like Mikey this kind of guy
and this is like that's pretty fun let's
let's try and go for you
they're like to like the idea of like
the whole like the whole world should
kind of play along and sing along to you
as you play so we're like you walk past
an object they know like have a certain
melody that plays along with the like
the background music what's Supernatural
about this game because when I first saw
a trailer but I just thought it was
going to be you know someone lost in the
woods but then I read Supernatural was
like oh there's a bit more to this game
than I realized
yes there there is magic in this game
there is like forces of nature we do
have at least one character that's a
ghost and I guess the people we get to
see what what other sort of magical
things they will they will encounter the
game is not only about magic though
there's also a lot of magical mechanical
puzzles as you saw while when you play
in the game so when making a virtual
reality game obviously there's there's a
lot more to think about in that sense
where you where you want them to look
and you know you don't want them to miss
things and also because it is a
platformer and you need to be you know
jumping and making sure you're not dying
I guess it's easy to get distracted when
you're in a virtual reality environment
so were there any difficulties that you
use somewhat across
yeah making this game was really odd
though let the fingers when you normally
make a game you kind of like making a
film or music you reference other people
you look at what they make it and you
say all I just felt like I've been maybe
we could do something like this but
because it was a new experience there is
no other sort of 2d platformer in VR it
has to do a whole load of prototyping
I'd say our a hundred ideas maybe four
of them get through because you don't
know what's going to work if the
constantly test it could constantly put
it to people and see what they think
because there is nothing to reference
like I say so it did take a lot of hard
work a lot a lot of man-hours to get it
done and another thing was like trying
trying to sync that 2d and 3d we didn't
want it to be like this is just a 3d
space in this 2d space we wanted that to
:
everyone who does it feel like you're
actually a part of that well so we had
to do a lot of stuff so when you think
of AR I know it's still very fresh and a
lot of people experimenting with it but
where would you personally like to see
it heading in the future I'm pretty sure
people will play along with the portals
you could go online you there will be a
lot of demos for air hit with portals
for you walk through the portal i
virtually became - out the virtual world
and then you you look around and then
you turn back and you see the portal
staying there and people in the streets
still passive area oh my god so you can
get it inside the portal a little bit in
a fully interactive way so basically
that means is that currently in
development or yeah Emily our kid allows
for that easy so I mean that means for
example you can put a portal in front of
you on a sidewalk and then walk into the
portal and find yourself in the same
street for example with you know Knights
going here and there and you know any
media medieval towns around you yeah
maybe I it can also use the geolocation
understand that you're maybe in London
or in Birmingham and that it's both
China understand what kind of
surroundings to show you that's amazing
because I mean that could be like
Elizabeth tear in Bioshock and a
question I want to ask everyone today is
I'm studying games development so very
much still a student if you could give
one piece of advice to a student or
someone trying to get into the games
industry what piece of advice would you
give that's a good question I don't know
like obviously play a lot of games but
also just like start yourself like
that's the way a bit about like if you
like if you want to do games then two
games you don't need like a degree you
don't need to like know certain people
or anything I think you're studying
you're your basement or whatever and
just start programming start drawing
start like have ideas make them make it
yourself I think that's that's the way
to go about it that's the only way you
can get it it's like practice have fun
DIY you know I think it depends so much
harder to get me in to see you want to
be in programming like well again I
don't know that's also depends on if you
want to be an Indian programmer or a
game to students
yeah because if this applied it's a
little bit different I just think that
you should just like try making games
simple as that
yeah it's a simpler stuff like just try
making different games on and see what
challenges arose on how to overcome from
my point of view it's work for yourself
be in D make stuff for yourself don't
make stuff to impress somebody else make
something that you want to make and then
hopefully that will impress somebody
else study basic product marketing I
guess because I think that's the part
that many many even experienced
developers just miss in their work you
know and it starts from the product like
know who you feeling for what exactly
the audience's who's the reference
customers what games they play where
they hang out because then it will gives
you give you a clearer idea those game
design and the road to the market you
know how are you how are you gonna what
publishers are going to approach with
your video with the game which shows you
will go to you which social media you
will use which press you will go to
etcetera etcetera which makes things so
so much
baylin's you can find more information
about the game on silence - 3.com that's
the website of the game the second
episode will be out at the end of
October find more information about
liquid and if you go to liquid and calm
you can follow us on twitter at in that
tub
Holbach studio as web sites Twitter so
under odd folks they just look for that
loss pair is on PlayStation Store the
game is out on this team where you can
get it for Mac and PC and Linux right
now and I'll be out in consoles later is
here hopefully and you can follow us on
Twitter on bedtime teaching thank you
very much